once again the woke go on a bender
asking grade school kids about their
gender elementary students in Oregon
recently received a so-called Health
survey that asked them to Define their
sexuality my doctor asked me that all
the time
weird thing is he's a podiatrist
it's 11 were asked whether they feel gay
straight queer or quote something else
but here's the kicker they got 12 gender
options to choose from including such
instant Classics as two-spirit a gender
Demi boy and Demi girl hmm what no Demi
Moore
I've been identifying as her to use the
Ladies Room at Planet Fitness
sign a lot of autographs
actually I'm tried binary if I can buy
it I'll try it
Oregon State Health
y says the survey is voluntary and
Anonymous voluntary and Anonymous hey if
it works for glory holes
yeah
I went there I mean I went to the joke
and I guess the choice to be groomed is
up to the kids according to its website
it's part of a new plan to quote ensure
that all Oregon Youth are healthy and
successful Learners because nothing
makes kids more successful learning than
being probed by creepy bureaucrats many
parents are outraged about this survey
which the school district reportedly
conducted in the past without telling
Mom and Dad and yeah it's Anonymous you
know it seems like they want the kids
parents in the dark now what kind of
adult stranger would prefer that but you
know I remember when the only ones
hiding stuff from parents were actually
the students man I still remember where
I used to hide those hustlers
Steve and Vic those guys were a barrel
of laughs mainly because I kept them in
a barrel
and they cried more than left
just admit you had magazines
I tried to cover it all up like yeah it
was two Hustlers between the mattress
that's where he kept them hotep where
are the adults this is driving me crazy
what happened to like teachers and
doctors and leaders how did we let this
poisonous garbage kind of basically
view into our educational system and
like nobody's stopping it there's not
one person going no this is crazy it
freaks me out well at this point there
are more genders than Baskin Robbins has
flavors of ice yeah okay so before they
assign the agenda I decided to pick up
my own gender so I chose astral gender
this is a real gender a 72 list blah
blah blah so astral gender is someone
who identifies with outer space and I
chose this because I need to get the
hell off this planet
hahaha
hello so we call this I call this The
Grooming bill that's exactly what this
is right but I represent hotep Nation
hotep Nations all about supporting the
home schooling Community it exists we
don't have to transfer people people are
moving there in droves but we want to
start pushing people to homeschooling
that's what we do and I think this bill
is a huge red alert and signal that
people need to start homeschooling yeah
definitely one part of that cat
again this falls into that concept of
age appropriateness like even like even
if I said questionnaire is fine but why
is why what do they have against the I
the concept of age appropriateness to be
able to say this is not for a kid you're
supposed to be a racist or a bigot if
you say that yeah in the sixth grade I
would not have known what any of this
stuff was in the sixth grade I was super
innocent though I remember before school
one day I burned my neck with a curling
iron
and then at school everyone was like is
that a hickey and I didn't know what
that was so I just said yeah foreign
and then I found out what it was and I
was like oh no but then I was like eh
that makes me sound kind of cool yeah
but of all the language in this whole
situation that makes me mad the thing
that makes me the most mad is government
funded because what let's we should call
it what it actually is which is taxpayer
funded yeah uh because you go to prison
if you don't pay your taxes but then
this is what they're spending that money
on exactly exactly I would prefer to go
to prison rather than have my kids being
taught this
it's disgusting Carly you're about to
pop out a baby
I am you are you I mean like this world
oh my God what's happening
[Applause]
I can do it
so I think uh this is why several
counties in Oregon have literally voted
to secede from the state and become a
part of Idaho I think Idaho just needs
to take him in at this point as a public
service uh but you are absolutely right
about how Wild this trend is where
adults are so interested in talking to
kids about sex now and when people
question them they claim the moral High
Ground exactly I'm not allowed to that's
if you are interested in talking to 11
year old about their sexual preference
there is there's really something wrong
with you and some of these are so weird
two-spirit is a term that was created in
the 1990s so relatively new at the
indigenous lesbian and gay international
grad gathering in Winnipeg
do you remember that I like the name
Winnipeg and it describes native people
in their communities who fulfill a
traditional third gender
an 11 year old is supposed to figure
that one out they take they've turned
sex education into perv education or
just a perv a perv hobby like if you
want to talk to kids about their sex
you're [ __ ] psycho excuse me
you know
Pirates don't children have enough
problems that you have to if there's
something like you got what
these teachers be terrified of you Tyrus
shouldn't they be God I don't want I'm
not going to talk to his kids about well
I don't have that issue because
um most I'm down to one all my kids are
homeschooled uh I pulled them all out
not not playing with that stuff uh two I
don't see the difference I'm not there
used to be a TV show on called Catch a
Predator right and what was the big
thing trying to get a grown man talking
to a 15 year old about sex yeah that was
Despicable deplorable he was arrested
the police dragged him out now that guy
can come to school and talk to everyone
there's no difference yeah absolutely no
difference my 11 year and I'm kind of an
expert because I have three 11 year olds
all different diversities so I you know
I know what I'm doing International
when I'm dealing with my United Nations
yes of children and across the board
they have enough time remembering the
chores they have to do let alone the
gender yeah the only one who's clever
enough is the eight-year-old who would
who would say any of those things to get
out of stuff yes yes I'd be like go to
bed um to Spirit
I don't identify with clocks
she's clever we're the 11 year old would
be like Dad I've never heard of any of
these candies I have no idea are these
candies good or bad my children are
innocent and homeschooled and the
eight-year-olds watch closely but I I
won't allow it a stranger to talk to my
children about the weather yeah let
alone like if you come up to my child be
like hello you will be greeted yes what
you need I'm right here that's what I I
it blows my mind I mean I I grew up in
the 70s this could people if a teacher
did this they would be disappeared
something would happen it's just so it
goes back to it's a small percentage
pretending to be larger than what it is
yeah yes and that small percentage are
right now are hiding behind again
femininity and education but it's the
same thing as if it was a dirty old
because when it's a dirty old man who
does it on the internet he's a pedophile
and I don't see the difference yeah all
right we got to move on
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else